we all have these ideas I want to start
a podcast I want to be a speaker the
successful people they're not smarter
than you often they're probably stupider
than you they just start all the
successful people that we profiled
whether they're entrepreneurs or
athletes or musicians or artists the
people at the top of their field if you
don't believe in your the abilities to
figure it out to believe that tomorrow
you don't have to be in the same spot
that you are today uh even when it
doesn't look like it your family's aren
doing your friends aren doing it the
people you know aren't doing it who are
you to be this crazy guy going off and
changing the world and doing amazing
things the believe that you could be way
bigger than you are right now that is
consistent across all the people that we
profile because you look at where people
came from chances are your hero started
with less than what you already have
right now the people you look up to
started with less than what you already
have right now if they can do it what's
your reason for not doing
it here live with Evan carmichel in go
man Sunny Toronto Canada my first time
visiting really yeah not that sunny it's
December but I guess I kiding about the
sunny okay okay it's like what 20
something degrees I don't speak American
us temperature yeah I don't know what
that is anyways it's freezing you can
see your breath during the day it's
about I think just around freezing yeah
just around freezing right now yeah it's
freezing went to a Tim come back in
February oh you went to Tims to Tim I I
went to Tims was a big fan what did you
get I got fail big fan big fan I got a
bacon egg and cheese on a on a something
on some bread and I got a french vanilla
latte oh wow you went sweet okay I
didn't realize it was going to be that
sweet it's sweet French vanilla is going
to rot your teeth yeah that was a lot of
but I will say was delicious big fan of
Tim Horton if I for those Americans
listening to this Tim Hortons is like a
a Wawa meets a Dunkin Donuts meets
Starbucks better quality food the coffee
was good yeah it's the Working Man
Starbucks here Tim Horton was a very
famous hockey player in Canada and he
partnered with Ron Joyce and they made
they made the franchise but it's like
you're either a Starbucks person or
you're a Tim Horton's person okay do you
have Dunkin Donuts here no what are you
are you a Starbucks person or are you a
TIm Horton's person
uh more Tim Hortons yeah what's your
go-to order at Tim Hortons extra large
one cream extra large coffee one cream
yeah that's it okay you're but if I have
anything I I could yeah then it'd be an
ice cap which is like a frappuccino but
better uh with a with a with one of a
farmer wrap which is like egg and
sausage with a hash brown inside it all
wrapped up I saw that it looked
delicious the hash browns in it's going
to be like 900 calories for that thing
is that keeps you fueled through all of
the YouTube videos are you a CO Coffee
Guy do you like to get caffeinated any
energy drinks uh no it's more appetite
suppressant I don't zero energy drinks
yeah uh and I don't use caffeine I don't
need caffeine to like get going yeah
it's just it allows me to fast for
longer you said appetite suppressant
does that help you get through the day
stay sharp for the YouTube videos do you
focus on staying sharp for me Diet has
had almost no impact like I could be
eating Snickers bars all day long and
still show up and be like let's go I'm a
film guys yeah uh and not have a giant
crash I would just be 30 lbs heavier and
still having energy like I think it's I
think for me the energy is much more
about the work that I'm doing like I'm
pumped that you're here we're having
this discussion I'm pumped for The 3day
Mastermind that I'm doing here like
that's what gets me going and if I was
eating crap or eating healthy like it
doesn't really make a difference but if
I hated what I was doing and I was
eating healthy like I wouldn't have any
energy it definitely helps I'm a I'm a
longevity I'm a biohacking guy I try
like optimize my nutrition I take all
kinds of weird stuff so that I can stay
sharp and operate as a superum
entrepreneur that's kind of my goal have
you ever tried to really fine-tune
nutrition maybe do some of those
biohacking tactics that that I teach to
to fully optimize yourself I mean always
I love it uh from nutrition to wearable
I mean got the a ring on tracking sleep
uh supplements trying all bunch of stuff
my new phase right now is anything I'm
doing I'm trying to take a data driven
approach to so we just did a panel took
eight fals of blood good tracking
Baseline for testosterone and just all
sorts of crazy stuff the guy who was
just here before you uh runs a DNA
company where it tests my DNA and it
gives you all sorts of reports on on
where you're likely to have issues or go
wrong and then and then how to how to
kind of fix all that stuff so I love I
love all that stuff but I found myself
uh at times buying into the hype of some
things and just doing it because
somebody said to do it but without ever
tracking so supplements was one of the
one of the worst in that I would I would
have been on you know 20 supplements
just because somebody said take the
supplement okay but I didn't feel any
different which may not be the best
indicator because it could be something
that it is actually fixing but I just
don't I'm very low just like I could eat
Snickers or I can eat super healthy and
not feel any different but my body would
be 30 lbs heavier but i' still have like
the stamina and energy right tracking
the metc tricks on the blood markers is
the way to go right so like one by one
so I I cut all of my supplements down to
just vitamin D and magnesium cuz I burn
magnesium like crazy yeah uh and vitamin
D pretty much everybody's deficient in
vitamin D especially if you're in
Toronto you don't get I try to get two
hours sunlight outside every day good uh
plus the vitamin D but after that
nothing and now we're taking an approach
of okay I got my blood markers what's
the next recommendation okay you're
going to try blank okay let's if it
doesn't show up in the blood work or
some kind of test then I'm not going to
keep doing it no that's fair there's a
couple things like fish oil that I I
just think you don't feel it every day
but there's so much research over the
years that shows it's I should be doing
more of his show there's lots of stuff
we can get into it anyways the reason
that I was excited to come talk to you
today and I think where we're going to
give the most value for for my audience
is with what you've done as a
motivational speaker now you were listed
on Forbes on Inc as one of the top
speakers in the country and you've done
a lot as an entrepreneur in your journey
to to build up credibility uh to finally
give back and make the impact that you
wanted to make through your books and
through your speaking uh so I wanted to
kind of go through the value lad that
you've created as a speaker you know you
mentioned that you're now doing the
masterminds okay oh we're going hard pip
at the business this is great hard pivot
to business yeah hopefully we can we can
have some fun here CU I'm kind of going
through that Journey myself a little bit
and you've done it so hopefully I can
learn a little bit from you and
hopefully the the audience can too
everybody wants to be a motivational
speaker right it's I I was looking at
search volume of like what have you done
that people are going to be super
interested in and this is something I'm
interested in everybody wants to be on
stage and make an impact and and reach a
massive audience uh but a lot of times
that doesn't happen right away you have
to have some credibility or be really
really good Y at speaking um what does
it take to be a motivational speaker can
anybody do it yeah I so you know if you
have a goal for something it's just
reverse engineering and and making
progress and steps every day towards it
I never really had a major goal to be a
speaker I don't like speaking that's
probably why don't like being on stage I
don't like being on stage how do you do
it for the impact like my my favorite
part of being on stage is to then have
six hours of conversations in the
hallway afterwards yeah so being on
stage is my least favorite thing to do
because I'm just I'm just talking yeah
where I'd much rather if I'm going to be
on stage much rather do something like
this like a fireside chat either with
the host or taking Q&A from the audience
right because I hearing myself talk is
not that helpful but if I know that I'm
bringing value to somebody through a
conversation it it it's more fun for me
um but I try to speak as early as
possible if it's a multi-day event I
want to go opening keynote or as early
as possible because I'll then spend the
next three days hanging out with people
in the hallway I'm introverted and shy
so like I'll never come up and say hey
how you doing I'm Evan what do you do
like I'll never do that but if I speak
and then I hang on the hallway people
will come and talk to me and that allows
for hours of of conversation as a
speaker and you get off stage there's
all this hype around you people just got
off you know watching you idolizing you
you want to be approached in the hallway
after I think it depends I do a lot of
people don't I'm a weird speaker people
get nervous to go up to speakers and
talk to them and ask them for a picture
asked them the question that they were
thinking throughout the talk yeah and
listen a lot of speakers don't like that
right a lot of speakers actually like
fly into an event do their keynote and
fly out I want to spend as little as
time possible there sometimes there is a
a a picture session with people that's
been contracted in sometimes there like
a bonus lunch for their VIPs or
something that's been contracted in but
in general the speakers don't hang
around they and they take off why do you
I don't like to speak I like to I'm
there for the community it's my it's
what I love the most and so some people
are like that and it's no right or wrong
it's just what do you care about I know
if I agree I feel like it's right to do
what you do well no it's that it's like
uh I remember I met um I was in New York
and Ryan holiday was in New York if you
know Ryan
and we just to be in the same city like
hey do you want to gra a breakfast
together like yeah let's do it so we
grabb breakfast and he asked me what I
was doing today I like oh I'm meeting
you and then I'm going to go uh hang out
with some fans and then at lunch one of
the people in my community took some of
my advice and grew this huge
multi-million dollar real estate Empire
and he wants to take me to lunch to
thank me like okay cool and the
afternoon I'm going to do a Starbucks
meet up with some other fans and then
I'm going to go home home yeah and he's
like well that sounds exhausting like oh
like what are you doing like I'm going
to I'm meeting you and I'm going to go
back and write yeah and he's he's sold
millions and millions of books right so
it's like for me it's not right or wrong
it's just this what style you lean into
I I like
Community um more than than uh I don't
know what I create or the or being in
the spotlight I don't like being the
spotlight right so speaking is a chance
to be in the in the audience I remember
the most recent event I was with Brendon
brashard was one of his speakers on
stage and Big Time guy yeah Brendan's
like one of the biggest in personal
development one the biggest yeah and all
the other speakers are backstage kind of
getting ready and talking to each other
in the green room all that and when the
doors are open it's like I want to be I
want the door opening the doors and like
high-fiving people on the way in even if
they don't know who I am I'm just like
hey welcome high five let's have a great
day it's not right or wrong I mean
strategically probably it would make
more sense to me to be in the back room
talking with the speakers and like
brainstorming The Mastermind in there
instead of just
people it's also way easier I feel like
it takes a lot more work to do what you
do I don't know if I have the social
battery to do that to work up the
courage and stamina to get on stage
speak for an hour and then come off and
hang in the hallway and do it all over
again as an introvert as a
self-described introvert that's actually
surprising that you are able to to do
that it's weird so I don't notice that
it's depleting me yeah and I need
somebody to save me from myself so
usually when I travel i' if my wife is
coming with me or I'll have somebody
else cuz it'll be 2:00 a.m. and I forgot
like I don't know what time it is I
haven't eaten I haven't gone to the
bathroom in 5 hours Jesus uh I'm running
a fever and don't notice it yeah until
I'm just so in the zone focused until I
get back to the room and then I then it
all like hits me like a truck and I
hiate for for two days no well it
depends what I'm doing I might like the
next day might be back at the conference
and and I can do that for a couple days
and then if it's past three days and I
start to really feel it what's the right
way to approach a speak you're at an
event if you're going to go to an event
I would say do your research on speakers
prior to being there uh try to find them
in the hallway before they speak because
after they speak everybody's going to
want to talk to them right so try to
find them before uh try to say something
personal like why you why you like them
what is it about them that you some not
just some generic thing like oh tell me
about yourself like they don't want to
answer that question right tell them
something specific that you found that
you really care about and then whatever
your ask is if you're ask is can I take
a selfie that most people will be as
long as they're not eating lunch or
something you know they're usually
pretty accommodating um or if you have a
question like what is the one question
that you want to you know ask to be able
to get that feedback is there a question
that someone's asked you before a talk
or after a talk that's left an
impression on you no but the the most
important question is the one that you
want you care about like the best
question and that I want people to ask
is the one that they care the most about
personally like how can I help you I'm
there to serve yeah and so this
frustrates me on my when I do podcasts
for people I actually made a video
before I go on somebody's show we send
them a video like here's how to prepare
for a conversation with Evan yes it's
like ask the question that you most care
about getting answered because what
often happens is one we might run out of
time or two we're filming and then
filming's done and they say okay so that
awesome Evan you know what I really want
to know it's like and then they it's
like lead with that question next time
right like why are we not filming this
because that's the best thing for your a
so a lot of times people when they're
making content they're only thinking
about Their audience and not about
themselves and understand that the
question that you care most about is
probably the one your audience will care
the most about as well yeah so what what
upsets me and not upsets me is it's it
happens so often it's I understand why
but like don't ask the safe questions
that everybody else is asking like why
did you write this book and tell me
about your whatever the SEC to grow on
YouTube yeah and unless that's what you
really care about right but like people
ask the safe question and then you get
the interaction I guess but you don't I
want to help you know if you can use my
name to help you line up another
interview or whatever cool but I'd love
to help you with advice as well yeah
there's no question that somebody asked
me that's like made me go back into some
Earth shattering moment but what about
the ask someone approaches you they ask
you a good question and they say hey
Evan I have a a new podcast that I'd
like you to join me on yeah is that
something you take them up on or is
there some kind of qualifier that's all
Vibe yeah for me it's all Vibe um it's a
good answer it's true yeah I again
different people look at different
things so for some people all they care
about is numbers yeah and who else
you've had on the show and how big is
your show and how many downloads you're
getting how many views you're getting
how many subscribers you have like it's
only numbers and that's the thing that
makes a difference so cool so you know
that so you work your way to getting
bigger numbers and it allows you to get
to the front of the line other people
they don't like I don't I don't care
about the number
um it's it's do I like this person yeah
do I want to spend an hour with them 30
minutes yeah and so I'll say yes to
people on on to do an interview and my
team was like what we have all this
other stuff that you're saying no to
like this person hasn't even launched
their show yet why are you saying yeah
but there's lots of people who haven't
launched a show who who I say no to as
well it's Just Vibe I've been People's
First guest and they never even release
the episode you know for whatever reason
they never even launched the podcast
even though I was their first guest
it's fine it like it is what it is yeah
like happy to help moving on to the next
thing right even this like here I'm
doing my three-day Mastermind here in
Toronto for entrepreneurs thought
leaders YouTubers and today is our
filming day but we had a couple of extra
spots yeah so like okay I got my film
crew here who do I want to invite up I
said let's let's see if you're free why
I don't know you know it's like I like
the vibe I like the first interview I've
done tons of first interviews with
people that don't go to around two yeah
and then I messag you and you're like is
there a cost to this thing like no man
use my film crew I got this space anyway
if you want to come to Toronto we'll
have some fun we go for dinner
afterwards he's like yeah I'm in well
why why you I don't know I like your
Vibe right like who would I have fun
with for an hour talking in Toronto I
don't have to do it I could I could take
a break we've already done two we're
doing more after right but I like it
it's fun yeah so but that may not be the
smartest thing to do I don't know I mean
for me it it allows me to stay uh
consistent cuz I think if you are only
using your head you end up doing a lot
of things that you don't like doing yes
and then you stop doing it yeah you got
to follow your gut and like it's got to
be fun and so I we've done content for
14 years something like that 2008 right
2008 I I opened the channel but 2009 was
my first video so even there like we
opened in November 2008 but April 2009
was my first video so even me I sat on
my channel like I'm going to start a
YouTube channel and then don't do
anything for six mon right like most
people yeah I'm just like most people I
just kept going yes so how do you keep
going well you love the thing right so
net it it all works out does the one
individual podcast sometimes it blows up
sometimes it does nothing sometimes the
person doesn't release the show yeah but
if I leave like I see you in my calendar
I was like this is going to be fun I
can't wait this going be great if I look
at in the calendar even if some even if
guaranteed big numbers but like I hate
this person or it's not going to be fun
it's a good way to think about your
day-to-day tasks are you looking at
these items on your calendar and saying
is this am I going to enjoy this or am I
dreading this yeah and the more you're
dreading the thing if you keep doing
that for the next 5 years you're going
to you're burn out you're not going to
like it better right you're probably to
like it worse and worse and worse and
that leads to burnout a lot of people in
the creative Community are like burning
out after a year of doing content right
like it's taxing I'm 14 years in and I
haven't burned out and we're making
daily videos but because you love the
work right so like if you love the thing
you're doing you're not going to burn
out from it starts to become more
rewarding too right once you start
getting process like talking to you is
the reward how well this video does I
don't
care so if you enjoy the process of it
you're going to you're going to succeed
if you had me doing accounting work for
an hour I'm going to start to burn out
too right I'm done like oh my gosh like
where's my no there's certain tasks that
even you have to do as an entrepreneur
once you're starting out that you get
off of your plate as soon as you
possibly can accounting legal want to
read any more cont H love HR I love but
yes accounting and legal for sure oh man
all right Evan you're my career
counselor and I want to be a
motivational speaker okay I'm a high
school kid I'm 18 what is the the path
that you put me on lay out a
trajectory well first says speak as much
as you can so start start doing speaking
gigs for free uh if you're a high school
kid then you're doing it at your school
yeah like how can you be a part of the
morning assemblies or whatever
announcements are on the on the the PA
or whatever they're doing right like how
do you work yourself you have to create
opportunities for yourself
but most schools for example are they're
not very creative they're not thinking
outside the box you say hey I'd love to
read the announcements every day or I'd
love to do this little skit in a of a
positive or motivational quote of the
day yeah can I do it and it's like okay
give it a shot right yeah so start
speaking speak at every assembly like
find a way in then look to outside your
school go to libraries go to Lions Clubs
go to anything you can volunteer to go
and just just practice speaking so
you're getting your reps in the more it
can be filmed the better because now
we're creating even it's off your iPhone
right it's like now we're starting to
create content that can be put up on our
Instagram on our YouTube ET speakers
real and stuff speaker all of it so it's
like putting in the Reps yeah plus
starting to get content if you want to
get better at speaking I would also say
make a daily video for your YouTube
channel or Instagram like solo direct
the camera without an audience just go
and speak because you're not going to
get an audience every day but you can
make a video every day right find
something that inspires you you know if
you're coming here to Toronto you talk
about your trip to Toronto talk about
meeting me you talk about how our last
interview went talk about what you wait
for breakfast like turn you anything
could be a motivational a spin on it
like you're coming to coming to Tim
Horton that you're excited something
novel something new going to try out
some Canadian flavors like in that story
the whole point isn't to get people to
try Tim Hortons the whole point is to
get people to try something new in their
life yes so but you coming to Canada and
trying out the bacon whatever rap might
inspire me to go do something new in my
life that's the whole point like the
story isn't to do the exact same thing
but you can attach a message to any
story to any story yeah right why you
chose to wear what you wore you're like
Jay you want to come to Toronto and why
you said right all of that right flight
booked let's go that is inspiring you
can turn that into a story so practice
because the best stories are the
personal ones but if it's just your
story it doesn't inspire me I have to be
able to internalize it to my life and
what I'm going through so if I'm trying
to get started in that career I'm
speaking as much as possible and in any
small venue possible I started the YMCA
speaking out of the YMCA and then
bookstores right the how old were you 22
wow so I stumbled into speaking right so
I I had my I had a biotech software
company that that I sucked at at the
beginning was making 300 bucks a month
but then built it sold it had some
success when I was 22 we exited and then
I got asked by my country to represent
Canada at uh ape event for youth it's
going to be entrepreneurs I would I just
exited so it's like young entrepreneur
success story we represent Canada to
this event in Mexico City it's like of
course yeah sure I what do you want me
to do you're going to speak on a panel
like okay so I went there and then
somebody at that event was from the
government of brunai which I didn't I
didn't even know what brunai was yeah um
and I said hey we're doing event for
young entrepreneurs can you come and
speak at our event and so I said sure I
can come do that and then when I came
back I like well why I speaking in
Mexico City in brunai like there's a lot
of Toronto entrepreneurs who might need
some help so I partnered up with the
YMCA and I said hey you have a program
to help entrepreneurs get started can I
come and speak to them for free just to
I don't know Inspire them yeah and they
said yes and the that first event had
three people show up for free what would
that feel like speaking to three people
I feel like that's a lot of people's
fear right speaking to an because I was
I'm I thought it would be a big deal
yeah they had this program
already and it was free
so they could they were promoting it and
telling people about it and they booked
this big room and then I'm nervous my
hands are sweaty you show up it's like
oh you walk in and my heart's like only
three people are here yeah this is this
sucks it sucks but three people were
here so I'm going to at least do my best
I'm not going to leave right um I mean
if nobody showed up that'd be great I
can go
home one person is worse than no people
so three people so I just helped them
and and then it was awesome I like this
is great and I don't know how I'm ever
going to make money doing this right
like if only three people show up to a
free event how am I ever going to make
money doing this but I don't know if I
will I just have to keep doing it
because I love it right and then that
three turned into five turned into seven
turned into 20 turned into and it just
kept growing um then we made more
Partnerships so I partnered with the
Royal Bank which is a one of the biggest
banks in Canada my audience is
entrepreneurs so banking plus
entrepreneurs made sense then we we did
out of their boardroom and then we grew
too big for their boardroom so then we
did it out of uh Indigo which is like
our Barnes & Nobles and we took the
flagship store in Indigo and I started
doing speaking there and I hosted a I
think it was every week or every two
weeks a speaking gig there and we had
the second most number of people at an
event in their store to sting sting was
number one and we were number two how
are you promoting these speaking events
how are people finding you why did they
want to see you speak it was a lot of
organic and slow right like three people
came to the first one they came back to
the second one and they brought a friend
then they came back the next one they
brought a friend not everybody came back
but a good chunk of people came back and
they brought a friend yeah YMCA promoted
it to their list at the beginning but
only three people showed up yeah then we
partnered with Royal Bank to use their
boardroom they sent out a a notice I
don't know was a flyer or an email or
whatever saying we're doing this event
it helps make them look good because
it's for entrepreneurs yeah nobody likes
Banks you don't think of banks as being
like friendly to entrepreneurs so here's
this free thing for you cool when we
went to Indigo the bookstore they
allowed us to put little flyers or you
know brochures or whatever marketing
leaflets to say we're going to be doing
this event but it was mostly that people
kept coming back yeah and then because
it's a physical event they have friends
and where you going here a good a good
job to get people back into the it was a
slow it was a slow like maybe it was two
years of doing that get to the point I
guess two different types of speakers in
the entrepreneurial world the ones who
have are like career speakers that start
early are really good they're
motivational and you can tell by their
stage presence they've been doing this
for a long time and then you see the
speaker who who has had a lot of
financial success a lot of business
success and they're brought on stage to
give back in terms of business advice
and sharing sharing their tips yeah uh
for the aspiring motivational speaker do
you think it requires them to have some
business success to prove that what
they're teaching Works do they need to
prove themselves first or not well it
depends what you're teaching like you
have to prove yourself inside of the
thing that you're teaching what were you
teaching when you started I was teaching
entrepreneurship very little like belief
or motivation with more entrepreneurship
like entrepreneurial tactics based off
of me going from 300 bucks a month to
exiting my company so telling my story
you have already had some success well
yeah so sure I had some business success
and having exited my business right you
I mean you can't teach on something that
you don't know yeah so you see people
try especially in the motivation world
yeah but but in motivation world you can
you can pull on your experiences yeah
but if you're if you're going to try to
teach about business you don't have a
business you're going to teach me about
paperclick ads and you never run a
campaign or it's like it's just too much
of a disconnect to do it motivation
could work as long as you've overcome
something so how what have you overcome
how have you gone through it that could
be inspiring for people same thing for
the business world you just have to have
some experience in the thing I think for
for Content creation you could do the
Journey of yeah I'm learning to to do
this join me on my
journey uh I think it's harder to do
from stage I think so too and I probably
harder to get that opportunity on stage
who's going to hire you know 19-year-old
Fred to come talk on stage maybe at the
YMCA but he has to maybe have had some
life experience that's where I'm I'm
wondering like if you're coaching that
that young kid is it don't worry about
speaking yet go get some life experience
or is it get better at speaking first
both like in getting better at speaking
you gain more life experience yeah so
what do you want to share what do you
want to talk about where does that come
from what what made you want to be a
speaker in the first place there's
probably some pain that you had to
overcome yeah you know so talk about
that pain and the more that you gain
more experiences the more stories you'll
have to share and tell yeah uh at the
beginning it's just about putting in the
Reps yeah that's most people worry about
like the the best first step and they
just overthink like the beginning of any
any habit we tend to overthink yeah
because we want to do it perfect if
you're going to start a biohacking or
Fitness World right where do you start
what's my what's my workout routine okay
well okay so I'm going to I'm going to
get my gym you know membership and then
okay I need to I need to research what
weights or do I do weights or do I
machines or do I do CrossFit or do I do
a running club or do I do yoga uh do I
need to get in maybe I need a personal
trainer I need I should get a personal
trainer and then over my nutrition like
do I do keto do I do carnivore do I do
and just like and then you don't do
anything because you're just thinking
and thinking and think analysis
paralysis because you're trying to make
it perfect yep but the best thing to do
is just like go to the gym
and do 20 push-ups yeah pick up a weight
and like don't hurt yourself or go to a
machine and just play with get better
anything right are five push-ups going
to do anything no but it's the fact that
you went to the gym and you did
something because if you keep showing up
then you can then you can apply the
signs to it then you can say hey your
form sucks on your push-ups do it like
this bring your elbows in or whatever
the thing is that you have to be doing
but the beginning phase is not having a
perfect plan the beginning phase is just
building some momentum let's talk a
little bit about the value ladder of a
speaker people look at Brandon Bard as a
great example of the the ecosystem that
they've created for themselves as the
business you know they kind of are the
company people are paying to see them to
interact with them in their masterminds
and read their books uh you've done a
lot of that for yourself uh what are
some of those elements to the value lad
that you've seen in common with a lot of
the speakers that you've worked with
over the years what do they have in
their ecosystem so you start with free
and and free is content and that's
usually YouTube videos Instagram Tik Tok
uh free downloads ebooks Etc and that's
top of funnel just to get people to
create awareness around your message
yeah and some people uh that's all
they'll lever consume is your free stuff
and that's okay like the
Free People Help get you to the paid
people yes moving from free to starting
to get paid to then higher ticket paid
and like bigger ticket paid Etc really
is just how much access they get to you
yeah so the next step up after free is
usually something like a book right so
the book you're selling for 20 bucks or
whatever but honestly at this point a
lot of a lot of speakers are just giving
away their book like here's my free book
it's just extra free there's you're not
trying to make money off a book at best
is a break even usually is some money
loss even if you self publish because
you're just trying to get your name out
there yeah um and you know books are
great I've done four or five of them
they're not as effective as they used to
be and you definitely don't need to have
one you if you have a YouTube foll
Instagram foll Etc that can be your
ticket in just as easily as a book
they're very sharable material too you
see people taking pictures and sharing
the books that they're reading on
Instagram all the time or recommending
books I mean and if if you love writing
and you have a message to share write a
book yeah if it's just a strategy don't
write a book like good advice I keep
thinking I should write a book I should
write I really don't want to write a
book yeah then don't like however long
it takes you to write a book and then
edit and then cover design and all that
and then promote there's so much better
things videos exactly which will go way
more viral if one of them takes off
compared to your book right but if you
have a message to share and you want to
write a book write a book like Ryan did
well writing books that's what he loves
he loves to write yeah great go write
after that then it's usually some kind
of group coaching in terms of the value
lad wouldn't be the order that I build
it in but in terms of price and value
letter then it's usually some kind of
group coaching group membership online
training Zoom rooms Etc
whether it's once a month or twice a
month um then you have some kind of
Group Training like a paid course behind
a pay wall with some Group Training
attached to it yeah paid course courses
are paid courses without without
Community I think are going to be
commoditized a lot of the content is
just getting out there for free right so
you can have a course but I would
definitely build in community and and
access to you even if even if just hot
seats like my group is movement makers
we have one called movement makers
that's for Thought leaders trying to
build their brand and the other is brand
lytics which is for just for YouTube how
to grow a YouTube channel Movie Makers
has a course attached to it and every
two weeks we hop on a call and we're I'm
not teaching the course you're expected
to have gone through this module and
then we do hot seats how can we go
deeper into the content that was up
there yeah instead of me coming on and
teaching each time um so so course group
work is that subscription or typically
like bigger onetime fee for Access you
can go both brand Linux is subscription
mve makers is a onetime fee cool um
after that then you should go some kind
of Mastermind group Mastermind group
it's what I'm doing here right we have
we have uh three days together creating
content teaching connecting with each
other there's going to be I don't know
how many people are going to be at the
event today but the you know movement
makers is a bigger group and then you
come down to like 5% of that are going
to come and meet in person and pay a lot
more yeah movement makers is about $7500
to $10,000 to join The Mastermind is30
,000 plus to join right in terms of
pricing and then on top of that speakers
would then have one-on ones so like
again it's degree of access to the
speaker one of ones is the most timec
consuming thing right so you don't want
to do too many it's going to be a higher
ticket price if I'm getting started I'm
trying to figure out how to monetize my
what order would you build free into
one-on
ones you get paid faster yeah you don't
have to build too much yeah and so like
this is where a lot of people get stuck
is they go and they build a c don't
build a course yes you don't even know
what people need yet like the best
courses are built after you've dealt
with people's problems so if you're
coaching people one-on-one and you're
helping them with all of their
biohacking and whatever right common
themes will come up hey Jay how do I
blank how do I blank you know I've seen
you with like devices on your head and
like you you're trying all of this
awesome stuff out right what are the
five to 10 most common things that
people are asking you then you turn that
into a course
most people start off with a course or
they start off with a book even start
off with a speech and it doesn't land
because when you're doing courses books
speeches there's no immediate feedback
right it's one to many so if you're
going to be speaking one to many you
better know how to speak to one to one
people because if you're doing a speech
you're really just talking to one person
you have to hit every person
individually but when there's no direct
feedback coming back to you you you
don't know it's working or not so how do
you know if it's working or not because
you've done it so many times oneon-one
right you know what the commonality with
what they're asking is typically about
your free content 100% you know you know
well free content but then also the
one-on-one paid work yeah because if
you're working with somebody one-on-one
you know the common questions they ask
you know your advice and then you also
know what the common objections are
going to be why they're not following
through they're not going to you know
they're not going to wear that helmet
because it's too expensive or because it
takes too much much time during the day
or because it makes my head feel hot or
because it whatever the reasons are when
you're dealing with people one-on-one
you get to understand all the objections
that they have as well which then when
you are writing a book or doing a speech
or doing courses you have to be able to
objection handle because they're
thinking it but they're not telling you
right so if they're thinking objections
but they're not telling you they're not
going to do the thing you want them to
do you might not know what those
objections are unless you've
had 100% what do you what do you
typically charge for those one-on ones
when you're just getting started maybe
you've made a few YouTube videos you've
got a small following and you want to
start making money from these one-on
ones it depends on how good you are you
know like so when I'm working with
people who are experts who are you're
really good at something my goal is to
get to a six-figure business as quickly
as possible and we'll usually look at
how do we how do we start off at 2,000 a
month what do we what can we offer for
2,000 a month and to get four clients
doing that that's almost $100,000
business crazy yeah if you have four
clients paying you every month at 2K
you've got a $96,000 business so you're
almost at six figures and for most
people that's a good Benchmark yeah but
how do you get to those four clients and
are you good enough so if you're just
getting started and you have no
experience and all you're doing is
speaking motivations it's probably going
to be hard to get four people to pay you
2,000 bucks and to keep paying you
that's the key thing is whenever you're
doing coaching don't think of it as a
one-off the first might be an
introduction call or whatever but your
packages default to one year if you're
content creator and you're working with
Brands don't do one-offs default to one
year it's where people are losing a ton
of money it's a lot of work to do the
first one and a lot less work to do the
continuity so if you're working with a
brand as a content creator it's so much
work to figure out how to integrate them
once and they're not going to get much
results out of one post make it an
annual thing what does that one year of
working with you look like do you get a
lot of push back on that ask if you want
to work with me it's going to be a
12-month commitment I feel like a lot of
people are worried about asking for that
they're looking for confidence yeah any
still situation they're looking for
confidence whoever's more confident
wins and so you can do this unethically
and like there's a lot of unethical
sales people who are pushing people in
the things that don't serve them but if
you believe that your thing can actually
help them if you're a coach of anything
what what are they going to get from one
session with you if you're personal
trainer okay they'll learn a little bit
in one session but te them some form but
it's like it's not really going to help
them get the results that they want
right so if you're actually good at what
you do the continuity is the thing
that's going to help move them along and
it's a combination of the the actual
tactics that you're giving them as well
as the uh the inspiration the
accountability the motivation like a
personal trainer half of their job is
just is psychology actually maybe 90% of
what they're doing is psychology and 10%
is the workouts and the meal plans and
everything else right you can give them
the perfect plan but they're not going
to follow through most people so like
that's your job is to push them beyond
what they would do themselves and so for
any any coach that's why am I working
with you I can give you some tactics but
it's the ongoing is where we're going to
see the results so as long as you
believe that that and you can genuinely
feel that and you tell them that you
have to tell them what to do they don't
know this world right like they're
stepping into your world so you need to
be the expert and tell them what to do
I'm going to try that 12mon thing I like
I think that's great advice what are you
coaching people on the most when I do
the one-on ones it's typically people in
my group training who have more specific
questions that I don't just want to
answer in like our slack Channel um like
this is going to require a deep dive
into like everything that you're doing
uh so it's typically $500 for 30 minutes
and typically during that time I'll
upsell something else that they probably
need what are you training them on like
what are the most common things that you
help people with uh typically it's their
marketing okay perfect so like marketing
is not just something that is solved
right away no it's so specific to each
industry and what they're doing yeah and
and then we need to whatever advice
you're going to give them whether it's
paperclick whether it's them making
video ads whether it's them creating
content whether it's their emails like
there's so much I don't know where you
specialize but in all of that lead
generation great so in the lead
generation the just teaching them how to
create a campaign is not going to get
them the results that they need right
your goal is hey for every dollar you
pay Jay I'm going to give you $3 back
and in advice and tactics and execution
and in in sticking to the plan that we
laid out so marketing is not something
that just gets solved in one call I mean
we could do that and it's 500 bucks or
30 minutes or whatever but what you're
really if we want to if you're serious
about this and and you can afford it
this really should be a $10,000
investment over the next
year and I'll work with you every
whatever that works out too that'll be
the next stage of my value letter I
guess because that's a lot more
commitment of my time than 30 minutes so
with with that over time over it could
still be the $500 an hour you can give a
slight discount or whatever right but
it's like even if whether you even want
to do that or not right when I'm working
with Consultants at the beginning like I
want you to be at least $500 an hour
that's so if you're if it's if it's
$2,000 a month that we're looking at
that's four hours max yeah right so
you're $500 for a half an hour I it's a
great spot to be and as you as you keep
getting more clients and more Rapport
Etc then you keep raising your prices
but lining up an annual program for
people not just gives you more
consistent cash flow and stream Etc but
uh get some better results yeah it would
I can help them at a much more intimate
much deeper level okay so we're going to
again next week or in two weeks and by
that that time you have to get these
these things done and then we're going
to start looking at your results so now
they're much more likely to get the
thing done because they're going to talk
to you in two weeks and they don't want
to look bad that they haven't done the
thing right where a lot of times if it's
just a oneoff you'll give them great
advice and not just you anybody give
great advice and then the the follow
through is mediocre they find some thing
ah yeah he said that but I don't think I
can do it because of they fall back to
who they were and come with all these
excuses why they can't do it which you
could easily if they were talking to you
you wouldn't let that stuff slide it's
like we said we'd get this campaign set
up yeah what's the problem the
accountability is is half of the just
knowing that they're going to talk to
you will make them much more accountable
to do it's like working out with a
trainer you know you're showing up at 7
a.m. like you paid them you're you're
showing up you can give them the best
video script to do yeah that will work
for their new Google ad campaign or
whatever they're going to create but if
they're afraid of being in front of the
camera then like they're not going to do
it because they have a issue that's
great cuz this is where I think I messed
up in my value ladder my one-on-one time
was these 30 minute $500 calls I agree
they should be commitments and there
should be some accountability there
because I'm probably not helping them as
much as I should be yeah well you
definitely aren't definitely aren't yeah
like they're not following through and I
would also book it as uh I for any of my
stuff it never goes to the full hour so
it's 25 or 55 just to give yourself a
break to then go to the bathroom or like
do whatever in between so it's always a
25 minute call or 55 minute session
everything my movement makers my
training it's always 25 minute or 55
minute and just think about what you
would sell it for so if you're going to
do $500 for half an hour how often do
they need to meet with you you know is
it is it every week is it every month is
it twice a month is it every week for
the first four weeks and then once a
month afterwards is it like and then how
much time does that actually cost me and
how many clients can I afford to take on
based on that time and you just you so
you can take on a Max of seven and so
you just after seven you keep increasing
the price how many do you have in your
private training how many can you manage
oh I I the the scale on top of that has
been I don't I don't really do one-on
ones unless it's some thing that we're
promoting yeah but how I've done it is
partnering with with
entrepreneurs so tell me more about that
what does that mean so I mean Drew here
is in the house right one of the guys I
partnered with uh people kept asking me
for YouTube training and and Channel
management like big channels people with
a million plus subscribers like hey can
you come on and help and what I would do
is hey I say Friday afternoons for my
friends so Friday afternoons almost
every Friday afternoon I'm talking to
some YouTuber as a friend or a friend of
a friends like giving them advice on
their channels like oh my God this is
amazing can you do this for us like no
I'm not I don't want to be on your
channel every two weeks talking to you
like I love you and this is great and
hopefully this help but I'm not going to
manage your channel because then I won't
be able to manage mine yeah so I
partnered with four different people who
do have different skill sets but like if
you want you can hire Drew and Drew will
do it for you yeah you've already built
up the ecosystem for your own channel do
you rent out that ecosystem is that is
that what you mean to other channels
your resour they don't rent out like I
don't do anything on my channel to
promote them they have their Channel
yeah they don't know what they're doing
not really their team doesn't know what
they're doing not really and so we'll
come in and help them and so I'll hop on
a free call with them and they get
incredible value and if they want to go
and run with it cool go and run with it
but they're like they're not going to
get much results and things are
constantly evolving and changing so Drew
will come in then and say well I'll
introduce Drew and say hey Drew you know
here's a potential client for you and
it's all you know the Drew would start
at what do you start at 2,000 a month 25
200 a month for strategy yeah 2K 2K is
like 2K a month is like starting
starting starting point yeah and then
and then it'll be split testing
thumbnails and titles it'll have its own
and then doing different mashups and
different strategies have different
tickets um and he's evolved into just
percentage a channel so great instead of
it just being a flat fee every month
like okay I'll take blank percentage of
your channel and I'll work with you to
continue to grow and so he's pairing
down how many clients he works with and
pairing up like the size of their
Channel how much revenue they make he's
invested into the growth of the channel
and I partner with Drew on that business
so I talk to Drew every week almost for
25 minutes
and I've done that with with Drew with
Jeremy with um this place here this Dan
studio right talk to Alex who helps me
run this for 25 minutes every week great
so figuring out how to monetize the
existing resources and network that you
have to help others so it's not costing
you your personal time one to one yeah
and so like Drew talks to I don't know
how many clients every week but I just
talk to Drew and if they try to skip to
me like I try to push it back to Drew
like talk to Drew yeah you have to be
good at that the the bigger you get the
more people that want your attention
being able to divert that attention to
the right places I built a GPT of myself
where I FedEd all of my YouTube
knowledge and now anyone comes to like
my Instagram or my YouTube comments with
a technical question I point them there
and it's been really successful so
that's great free content yeah and then
you see the people who have if you're if
people don't have money they value their
money more than their time yes and so
they'll explore all sorts of free stuff
and that's great and like I I produce
tons of free content every day the
people want to go faster who have money
they value their time more than their
money yes and so they pay for Speed and
so they just come on and they want to
they want you to tell them what to do
and then they go off and do it and so
they value expertise and so those are
the people are that's it's a tiny
percentage of the people who will be
following you yeah but the Free People
lead you to the paid people 100% And
then those people you continue to if
you're only going to work with seven
clients well as you get bigger and you
retain your current clients and now
there's more demand then you start
raising the prices but everybody's on a
one-year program your most recent book
the 10 secrets to success okay uh you've
spent a lot of your career highlighting
some of the greatest entrepreneurs of
our time and before our time and
learning from them what are those 10
secrets to
success and tell me a little bit about
this newest book um I don't remember
what all the 10 are in the book The
First about the the biggest takeaways
that you've you had is is the biggest
one yeah and that's what I found uh
consistent across all the successful
people that we profiled whether they're
entrepreneurs or athletes or musicians
or artists the people at the top of
their field if you don't believe in your
maybe not current abilities but the
abilities to figure it out if you're
some young speaker on the come up it's
like okay well you don't you don't have
any abilities yet but the belief that
it's possible Right the belief that
tomorrow you don't have to be in the
same spot that you are today
uh even when it doesn't look like it
your family's not doing your friends
aren't doing it the people you know
aren't doing it who are you to be this
crazy guy going off and changing the
world and doing amazing things like the
belief that you could be way bigger than
you are right now that is consistent
across all the people that we profiled I
think it's ego belief
conviction um there's a healthy number
of people have a big ego you have to I
don't know that you have to have a big
ego but confidence in your ability as to
figure not even confidence in yourself
but confidence in your ability to figure
it out yeah I think that is consistent
yeah because you look at where people
came from chances are your hero started
with less than what you already have
right now the people you look up to
started with less than what you already
have right now if they can do it what's
your reason for not doing and there's
tons of reasons why you're not doing it
but like it's only easier to grow and
build and create you know I look at
Oprah who had such a crazy upbringing
and the rape and all this stuff but um
one of my favorite stories was she she
was raised by her grandmother who was
poor and she had to go to school her
grandmother couldn't afford clothes for
her so she would buy potato bags bags of
potatoes to eat the potatoes and then
she'd take the bag and sew it into a
dress and Oprah would wear potato sacks
I've never heard that story as a dress
going to school you can imagine like
school sucks already kids are making fun
of you got and now you're showing up to
school in a potato bag now obviously it
wasn't just like cut garbage bag but
still it's like it's it's a potato bag
that's your dress for school no I can't
imagine it's inspirational for for
anyone and she can go from that to where
she is now like what are you what's
without the internet it's like yeah
what's your excuse belief number one
belief uh any other highlights from that
book success tips that you feel like all
of these leaders have had in common the
willingness to start and then the
courage to keep going so we all have
these ideas I want to start a podcast I
want to be a speaker I want to be a
whatever like we all have these great
ideas but the successful people they're
not smarter than you often they're
probably stupider than you they just
start they just like okay I'm going to
start it's going to suck whatever yeah
it's like
even lowering the expectations just so
that you can go off and do it yeah like
lowering the expectations of what you're
going to get out of the gym and just go
and do five push-ups people aren't
willing to suck at the beginning right
we want to bef YouTube specifically my
partner people are scared to start
recording videos with no one watching
like speaking on stage with three people
yeah but you have to do that for a while
before people start watching well but
here's the thing you're afraid that
nobody's watching yeah but you're also
afraid when people are watching yeah if
you get on a sage is a thousand people
it's your first time you're afraid too
right it's fear no matter what right so
it's like Fe just start it's actually
better to start when there's nobody
watching yeah right so just start just
go and crit and so successful people
just start whether it's lowering the
threshold for what good is uh or just
expecting to suck it's just go and start
and then the consistency to follow
through right so
uh they just don't quit if you look at
my YouTube channel the numbers are on my
homepage but it's like 5 years in I
still had 2,000 subscribers wow and that
was back in 2009 through plus five years
but like my first year had 25
subscribers wow second year was like a
100 it's on the website it goes year I
don't remember at all but like year five
it's 2000 something so it's easy to say
oh I suck I mean it's not just I tried
once I mean this is 5 years in yeah five
years that's
making yeah exactly like this I've given
this a shot you know it wasn't always
every day it wasn't every day but it's 5
years you know but I just kept going so
the first five years were zero to 2,000
and the next five years were 2,000 to 1
point something right million every
YouTuber will say the the key is
patience and persistence too like
clockwork just consistency don't stop I
think you can learn and you can I mean
didn't I didn't have I didn't have role
models to look to there were no YouTube
courses or classes um and I was too
embarrassed to ask for help too shy to
ask for help so like if I could do it
over again I I could get there faster
but it's still a journey and I'm
introverted and shy don't like the
camera and like all of this stuff I'm
not technically savy like all of the
things that right but through trial
figured it out but I just kept going yep
right and so like the willingness to
keep going why because I loved it like I
loved it I love making videos even
though I don't like being in front of
the camera I love making it's a weird
it's a weird thing so I I just kept
going and you see successful people they
just keep going
and for people watching this they can
there's a lot of strategies you can use
now to get there faster there's a lot of
how many mentors are online even if you
never join a mastermind or anything
people sharing content of how to win in
anything in biohacking and digital
marketing and lead generation and
YouTube there's there's so many people
now sharing content that like didn't
exist you had to figure a whole bunch of
stuff out then now people are teaching
for free like if you were getting
started you can get there a lot faster
too 100% there's no reason why you can't
go off like people watching you you
can't go off and go create something and
get there faster than Jay did or Evan
did yeah and my shortcut was buying
courses so what you say it's it's
completely correct all right one more
well listen too like some courses are
waste of money right been if you guys
heard me said buying courses courses I'm
sure like out of the 20 courses you
bought there were like two that were
awesome and 10 that were okay and eight
that just completely sucked yes right
where people or whatever the numbers are
you know and that but it's not like 18
18 out of 20 were awesome and I love
some are awesome some it's like I got
one thing so maybe it was worth it and
then some it's just a waste of your time
and that will happen yeah you know that
what happen and so talking about the
ladder if you're trying to figure out
how to work with somebody I'd say
consume their free content first if
you're thinking about Jay watch his free
content first let them prove to you that
it's worth investing a little bit more
yes then buy whatever the cheapest
course is a membership or whatever let
them prove to you that it don't just go
out and hire Jay and pay him $10,000 for
a year right like taste and test the
waters along the way and for anybody
that's how you avoid getting ripped off
because if they've proven to you every
step along the way if the free content
made you $5,000 cool invest a hundred
bucks in something yep if that made you
10,000 cool right so let the person
prove to you along the way that it's
worth it love that and make good really
good qu quality free content it makes
selling the paid content a lot easier
for sure let's get one last success tip
from the book and we'll wrap it up what
is your your your third top takeaway
from the 10 success tips so the
willingness to model success
and something that helped me back a lot
at the beginning was like I I was trying
to figure it all out myself and I I
didn't ask for help I felt embarrassed
asking for help I felt foolish not like
being able to have the I pride of myself
able to find the answer yeah which is a
good thing to have like I will go and
figure this out that's great but you
don't have to do it all
alone and so whether it's asking Jay for
help or joining your community or um
listening to podcast or watching a book
or
going to an event even if the event
sucks and you learn nothing if you keep
going to events you'll you'll pick up
something from one of them and so just
every time that I try to figure out
myself I eventually do but it's slow
yeah every time I go especially in a new
area and I I don't know anything and I
ask for help and I I get feedback great
like if I want to learn digital
marketing or lead generation I'm
starting off and I want to learn lead
gen I could do it and I can go through
all the cour but I could also just ask
Jay and he's going to like shut my path
and I still probably don't ask for help
in that
I don't think any of us do I think it is
a really important skill it's a it's a
great reminder yeah right like I'm
making this video is for
me Jay's gonna clip this and then send
this to me in six months EV you asking
for help just recognizing you don't have
to do this all by yourself and you
shouldn't do this all by yourself great
tip and investing in those relationships
like this this one here starting a
podcast making a network so you can pick
up the phone when you encounter a new
problem want to learn a different skill
super helpful Evan this has been a blast
thank for coming on the show you're an
inspiration to me uh I hope to follow in
a lot of your footsteps cool thanks for
coming up man thanks San love Toronto to
see me coaching another entrepreneur
one-on-one check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I had 5 years to get to 2,000
subscribers or something like that the
only thing I had going for me was I just
kept going it wasn't very good on camera
I didn't have any strategy I didn't
really know what I was doing